On November 6th
there's an election.
You might be thinking-
Wow, a new president already?
No.
This is not
a presidential election.
It's the mid terms.
Senators.
Congress people.
Governors.
Local officials.
All Americans are asking
themselves-
The same questions.
Should I vote?
How will I know
that I should vote-
If celebrities don't tell me to?
Does Emma Stone think
I should vote?
What about John Krasinski?
Have you guys seen
A Quiet Place?
Yes, but that isn't what
this is about right now.
It's about celebrities-
Telling regular Americans-
That they have to vote.
Many normal Americans like us-
Don't know what we should do-
Until celebrities tell us
what to do.
Should I moisturize?
Jennifer
Aniston says you should.
That's a yes.
But should we vote?
Some people are calling
this the most important
election of our lives.
But they aren't famous.
Chris Tucker.
Lady Gaga.
Kendrick Lamar.
Will Smith.
Should I vote?
Tom Holland, Tom Hardy, Thomas
the Tank Engine, should I vote?
Barbra Streisand, Barbara
Walters, all the Barbaras.
Ethel Merman?
The Harlem Globetrotters.
Angela Bassett?
Kylie Jenner's baby.
Bruno Mars.
The cast of Riverdale.
Your silence is deafening.